we have new information for the manhunt
for University of Connecticut senior
he's accused of two murders now police
believe that Peterman Fredonia took an
uber to a Pennsylvania Walmart after he
allegedly killed an acquaintance on
Sunday he was last spotted walking on
train tracks nearby as Errol Barnett
reports police consider him armed and
dangerous and they're warning drivers he
may try to hail another rideshare we're
asking if anyone sees the suspect to
please call 911 do not approach him
Connecticut State Police Tuesday
released a detailed timeline of a
multi-state crime spree allegedly
involving 23 year old Peter man Fredonia
the suspect had committed a home
invasion Sunday morning and stole
multiple firearms man friend Onias
accused of killing two men including his
acquaintance
23 year old Nicholas Isley on Sunday he
then reportedly took Isley's girlfriend
captive she was later found safe what is
it you heard saying just yelling and
banging Gino says aroni lives in the
same building as Eisley and said he
heard noise from his apartment Sunday
morning
because of what happened to him if we
reacted and called the police at six
o'clock who knows they would have
pretended that's black hole police said
a car was stolen Monday near East
Stroudsburg Pennsylvania where man
friend dona was last seen the black
Hyundai Santa Fe has Pennsylvania plates
reading KYW 1650 CBS News has also
learned man Fredonia's father was
charged with several crimes last month
including second-degree sexual assault
he is free on $50,000 bond man Fredonia
family attorney Michael Dolan declined
to comment on the father's charges but
said the family wants Peter to know they
support him I'm here to aiding in your
defense to help you through this process
police are pleading with man-friend onea
to surrender your parents your friends
all of us back here in Connecticut want
a peaceful end to this now the man
Fredonia family attorney does
acknowledge that Peter suffers with
mental health issues but they won't
discuss whether or not the family has
been in contact with Peter since this
all began so that's a possibility
the FBI is assisting in this
investigation but what's puzzling so
many is that the police have not yet
detailed a motivation for these alleged
crimes so so many people feel at risk
and of course Tony if anyone sees this
young man call 9-1-1 arrow thank you
very much